there's still a lot of confusion over uh
geithner's new plan and the legacy loans
and the legacy securities program and
how much leverage does it allow and what
are all of the different ways to gain
the system and and and to be frank the
more i read about it the worse it begins
to look and and everything that i've
talked about in in the previous videos
about how you could game it and the
amount of leverage and the insurance
that the government is giving away for
free is actually worse than i originally
thought so just to clarify things
so if we you know we could call it the
the public was it called the public
private investment was it fund or
program or whatever it's called you know
i call it the geithner plan
there's actually two different plans
here
there's the
legacy loans plan
legacy loans
and then there's the legacy securities
plan
legacy
securities
everything i've talked about so far
has been the legacy loan plan and
actually that's that's my bad because
it's really the legacy
securities plan that's a lot shadier and
just to be clear legacy loan plan is if
there's some bank
over here
it's got on its books let's say it has
some actual loans you know these could
be construction loans or loans for uh
commercial housing whatever it's just a
group of loans out there that it needs
to get off of its balance sheet that's
what the legacy loans program allows to
do some private investor can contribute
seven dollars the treasury will
contribute another seven dollars the fed
will give a
eighty six dollar loan
and then they can use all of that money
and actually i should have done it on
the other side of the balance sheet but
this will be let's say a hundred dollars
of
buying power that they can go use to buy
these loans off these banks and that's
fine
and you know everything i talked about
before the put option and all of that
that still applies here
you're still getting uh depending on how
you view it either six to one leverage
or 12 to one leverage depending on you
know
how you want to think about it but
everything in the last videos apply but
but what's kind of shady here is this is
the this is the program that they're
allowing they're opening up to everyone
or you know anyone who can kind of
navigate uh you know all the paperwork
and how you can get included et cetera
et cetera but essentially a bunch of
hedge funds and investment funds can
participate in this and
because there will be so many
participants it'll be probably pretty
transparent but what's
weird about that is that
legacy loans although that is part of
the problem with all of the illiquidity
that's happening that isn't kind of the
crux of the problem the crux of the
problem were all these mortgage-backed
securities and collateralized debt
obligations and all of that and those
don't apply in the legacy loan program
so the thing that you're applying to
everyone isn't the thing that's really
the big problem with on sitting on banks
balance sheets most of the toxic assets
that everyone talks about
so most of the things that you know when
let's see there's another bank's balance
sheet this is its liability this is
equity most of the toxic stuff that
people are talking about let's say this
is a toxic asset
these aren't legacy loans these are cdos
or
derivative cdos or mortgage-backed
securities whatever you want to view it
and these fall under the legacy security
program and these are the things when
everyone talks about the markets only
willing to pay 30 cents on the dollar
while the bank's only willing to sell it
for 60 cents on the dollar that applies
to this reality here and when you look
at the legacy security program it is a
lot shadier than the legacy loan program
this one is open to anyone or for the
most part anyone this program right here
it's only going to be open to
five investment managers five
managers
and it's not like you know there's a 500
people could compete to be those five
managers they've actually set the bar
pretty high on who can be a manager you
have to have 10
billion
under management
and not not total assets under
management
10 billion of this kind of stuff already
under management so you have to have 10
billion dollars already under management
of collateralized debt obligations and
mortgage-backed securities and then the
maybe out of all of these the less
strict thing is that you have to show
the ability
ability to raise 500 more
million dollars to participate in this
plan so even though they say that you
know you have to apply to be one of
these five managers there probably
aren't more than five managers already
out there who have 10 billion under
management of these types of securities
i mean if you have 10 billion of these
types of securities you probably have
hundreds of billions under management
and frankly you know two names come to
my mind immediately i haven't done
enough research on this to figure out
who the other three are but
pimco
and blackrock are definitely going to be
included in that group and then there's
going to be three other people so even
though the geithner is making it look
like it's some type of competitive
process he's essentially already picked
to the people and i'm sure he's already
had conversations with the five guys who
are going to participate in this because
he wouldn't have projected out this
number five unless he already had the
agreement of these two guys and then and
then three more and then what makes this
even shade you're not you know obviously
this is going to be more closed and more
more uh more opaque to the outside world
and what's going on you know you could
easily get five guys in a room and and
kind of make a deal what makes it even
shadier is that the leverage
allowed in this program is even more
extreme than the leverage allowed in
this program
so here just to give you you know let's
say i had pim rock and that's the that's
the mythical firm that everyone is
talking about now
what you could do now is instead of
doing putting seven dollars of equity
you could actually put in
you could actually put in
350 of equity
350 of equity
the treasury is going to put in another
350 of
equity the treasury is going to put
another 350 of equity so so far it looks
a lot like everything i've described so
far so this is from the treasury
and they allow this program allows a
further hundred percent of the equity
base loan from the treasury so then the
treasury will give let's see let me do
loans in in yellow
so the treasury's willing to give
another
seven dollar loan
to this fund that we're creating and now
we have once again fourteen dollars and
then this fund can then participate in
the legacy talf program and the legacy
taf program involves the fed essentially
you know giving you this six to one
ratio and actually it's up to their
discretion so a lot of this is going to
be opaque to you know us by standards
but you know i i have a sense that
they're probably willing to give even
more leverage but let's say that's the
same leverage that everything we talked
about in that plan so you're essentially
going to have another
eighty six dollar loan from the fed and
i know it's getting messy
eighty six dollar loan
and now this manager
pim rock who only contributed 350
will control
one hundred dollars
one hundred dollars of buying power so
this becomes one thirty to one leverage
thirty to one leverage where the loan
isn't just from the fed anymore
right this is the fed loan eighty six
dollars but there's also a fairly large
loan coming from the treasury and you
know we all know a lot of people have
emailed me and said hey what happens
when these loans go bad and the fed
takes a hit the fdic becomes insolvent
well i think the fdic knows the answer
to that question it's you know anything
issued by
our our dollar bills we have those are
federal reserve notes they're issued by
the federal reserve but they're backed
by the treasury so essentially is that
you know the
the the federal reserve is a government
sponsored entity just like fannie mae or
freddie mac and essentially says if the
federal reserve or the fdic ever goes
bankrupt the treasury will take the hit
so really even though this is a
loan from the fdic or from the federal
reserve it's being backed by the
treasury so all of this is a loan from
the american people
right here essentially
i wanted to make and so this actually
hugely changes the economics of kind of
the put option relative to the video
that i made here on the put option
an investor here this is an equivalent
put option just so you you get a sense
of it if you were going to pay
thirty dollars
for something
in my previous video i said well you
instead you could put
you this is you know this is
non-geithner
this is the non-gotten reality now in
this reality if you are one of the
select five individuals who are allowed
to participate in this program what you
could do is you could put in
250
let me make sure i get the numbers right
no you could put in 225 let me draw it
out you could put 225
of equity
the treasury will put in 225 of equity
so that's what 450 then the treasury
will give you another
450 loan
450 loans so we have about nine dollars
what is that that's 450 yeah we have
nine dollars and then the fed will give
you a 51 loan let me do that in a
magenta
so the fed will give you a 51 loan and
now you have sixty dollars of buying
power
sixty dollars of buying power
which you could use to buy two of the
securities you would have bought in the
nine got non-geithner scenario the
reason why i say you wanna buy two
scenarios is because i want to show you
that you get because you have to split
the equity right this goes to the
treasury
this goes
to
pim rock
right
so since you have to split the equity
you actually want twice the large of a
position to get the same upside right so
this is a reality where pimrok has only
put 225
of risk of capital at risk but they're
going to get the same upside as they
would have gotten in the nine guy in the
non-geithner scenario
putting 30 at risk right and you could
work out the math if this thing ends up
if this thing ends up being worth 40
then this thing ends up being because
you could have bought two securities
with this two thirty dollar securities
two thirty dollar securities so then
this thing will become worth eighty
dollars
and then each of these so that twenty
dollars of profit right you had sixty
dollars before of assets now they're
worth eighty that twenty dollars of
profit would be split between pim rock
and the treasury so ten dollars of
profit each so in either case you would
benefit ten dollars but obviously in the
downside scenario these guys take most
of the hit but let's do let's very
quickly value that option
right because you could have either
put just 30
of your capital at risk to invest in the
security or in this scenario you could
put 225
into the fund
and then you could have put what is it
27
75 in cash or treasuries or essentially
money that's not at risk
and the payoff diagram here will look
something like this
that no matter what the price of the
security let's say that this access is
the price of the security
that's the price of the security and
then this is the value of your
investment
so in this reality it's just a line with
slope one
where if
let me draw that out
where if your investment
is 30 if it ends up if if the price of
the security ends up being worth 30 your
investment is at 30. if the price of
your security ends up being
60 the value of your investment is 60.
that's in the non-geithner scenario in
the geithner scenario
you make all of this money if your asset
pays off
but if your asset price drops below
27.75
right there
you're made whole because you just you
put 27.75 in cash so the payoff diagram
for the
the the talf
legacy loans or legacy security program
looks something like this
and this is
essentially
you owning the security plus the plus a
put option
right and just to value that put option
let's see
so if we say the stock price security
price is 30 these aren't stocks these
are securities the strike price on your
option it's a put option at 27.75 you
have the right to sell the security at
27.75 interest rate we can make it
something pretty low
because we're not going to borrow the
dividend yield is pretty high on these
things because they're yielding a lot
and then the volatility we could say
it's pretty high and then the time to
expiration we could also say is pretty
high because these are going to these
are going to be 10-year options
essentially 10-year american options
because there's no you can exercise them
at any point and when i click hit
calculate
i get the value of the option
and these are actually american put
options so 21.50 approximately
so for thirty dollar security
for what was a thirty dollar security
the government between the treasury and
the fed is giving an approximately a
twenty two dollar
a twenty two dollar free
put option
free put option and so they're
essentially giving you an incentive to
pay as much as you know all all you know
well over 90 percent of above the true
value that you would have otherwise been
willing to pay for the security you'd be
willing to pay you know you'd be neutral
if you were neutral at 30 now you'd be
willing to be neutral at
50 or 52 dollars
for each of these units of security so
this changes the economics dramatically
you know this this by itself might
actually close the bid ask gap but
obviously most of that is coming from a
subsidy from the government in the next
video i'll show you kind of how this is
actually a huge incentive also to game
it because
these pim rock guys these five fund
managers they also have a huge inves
interest in up in in participating in
this plan even if they thought that this
was a bad investment because they can
make so much money on the rest of their
portfolio and i'll do that in the next
video see you soon